le juge lambert témoin vedette à la cour
d'assises de dijon le petit juge comme
on l'appelle familièrement instruit le
dossier grégory il y a quelques années
il ya neuf ans c'est lui qui avait
souvenez vous inculper bernard laroche
et christine villemin
ses explications sur les ratages
policier judiciaire était très attendue
ce matin
d'entrée de jeu il a déclaré qu'il ne
croyait pas à la piste la roche compte
rendu d'audience dominique verdeilhan
eric de l'agneau jamais un témoin n'aura
été autant attendu par la presse comme
par la justice jean michel lambert c'est
la concierge du palais qui lui montre le
chemin car la cour d'assises l'attend
depuis deux semaines mais bientôt la
tâche est trop dure et ce sont les
policiers qui vole au secours du petit
juge lorsque jean michel lambert est
arrivé à epinal en 1980 ses collègues
lui avaient dit ici il ne se passe
jamais rien on connaît la suite
à 9h45 ce matin le juge près son entrée
dans la salle d'audience
lorsqu'il arrive dix minutes plus tôt à
dijon le juge sait déjà ce qu'il va dire
une question posée à la cour d'assises
est ce que bernard laroche pouvait
savoir le 16 octobre 84 que christine
villemin laisserait grégory devant la
maison
cette question je ne me la suis pas posé
dès le début je lave ou pour moi la
réponse est négative
il y a là une invraisemblance qui est de
nature à innocenter bernard laroche le
silence est total dans la salle jean
marie villemin accuse le coup à la barre
le juge lambert persiste et signe sa
deuxième piste et pour lui la bonne
pourtant à aucun moment le juge lambert
n'a cité le nom de christine villemin
mais tout le monde a compris des erreurs
j'en ai commises mais je ne fuis pas mes
responsabilités
lens sûr de lui le petit juge mais jean
michel lambert ne semblent pas percevoir
que les questions du président olivier
russell ce ne sont guère flatteuse à son
encontre le président de la cour
d'assises lui rappelle ainsi ces
questions ambigu vis-à-vis de christine
villemin
les oublis de son enquête les expertises
annulé faute de procédure où les scellés
qui ont disparu le président de la cour
d'assises souligne également l'aspect
influençable du magistrat face à
certains témoignages et face aux
enquêteurs
devant cette mise en cause le petit juge
jean michel lambert ne semble avoir
qu'une seule réponse
neuf ans après ce n'est pas évident on
serait tenté lui dire
la faute est